[Musique]
en janvier dernier jean jacques bourdin
et sa femme anne nivat était invité dans
tpm thê-anh niva et jean-jacques à la
fin d'émission la société de production
h2o avait affrété un taxi pour piéger le
journaliste en vue d'une diffusion pour
son émission la grande race rare mais le
piège ne s'est pas passé comme prévu
interrogé par adel le faux chauffeur le
couple aurait déballer son sac et eu des
propos pas très sympa envers cyril très
agacé par ce piège jean jacques bourdin
aurait appelé syrie pour lui demander de
ne pas diffuser les images de cette
caméra cachée on imagine pourquoi
aujourd'hui c'est anne nivat qui est
revenu sur cet épisode au micro
d'europe1 effectivement nous n'avons pas
voulu puisque c'était caché que ça soit
diffusé et nous avons eu raison comme
quoi la barca n'est pas du goût de tout
le monde
mais durant cette caméra cachée que
s'est il vraiment passé ce soir à dell
de faux chauffeur qui a piégé le coupé
est avec nous pour tout nous raconter
merci à dell d'être là mon chéri un
grand merci de recevoir le piètre
comédien ah ouais alors attendant on va
voir ça alors on va écouter la barre ce
qu'a dit on y va sur europe 1 c'était
chez philippe blondel
quelques jours après la parution de
cette info dans le parisien c'est
michael holt aubenas qui avait trouvé
cette info il est donc voilà il ya fini
monde elle qui a interrogé la femme de
jean jacques bourdin pour savoir si
cette histoire était vraie ou pas
regardez vous aviez participé à touche
pas à mon poste dans le taxi du retour
aux éthique jean jacques bourdin le
chauffeur vous demande alors ce que vous
pensez de cyril hanouna l'annoncé pas du
tout comme ça ça s'est passé le couple
aurait alors critiqué allègrement le
présentateur de c 8
ils sont chauffeurs des tec d'infos
soffer c'était un piètre acteur
voilà embauché par les équipes de cyril
hanouna pour nous faire tomber dans ce
piège nous a absolument pas posé cette
question sinon ce serait absolument tout
de suite rendu compte
effectivement c'était une caméra cachée
et effectivement nous n'avons pas voulu
puisque c'était caché que ça soit
diffusé et nous avons eu raison mais
donc peut-être qu'il quelqu'un à la
bonde absolument par exemple été
détruites et de toute façon si quoi que
ce soit réparé ça sera une violation de
la vie privée une violation du droit à
l'image
voilà donc apparemment nous menace bien
on y va et jean jacques bourdin alors
sachez le nous ça s'était très bien
passé quand on les avait reçus
oui je les aime beaucoup les deux voilà
donc c'est vrai que alors je vous
explique ce qui se passe c'est que moi
il m'appelle
à 21h45 me disent oui cyril qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
on a été piégé il faut absolument cette
voie là brûler les images brûlé une
bombe
on ne veut pas de voir ça repart je sais
même pas de quoi même pas de quoi donc
j'appelle mes équipes et je leur dis
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
est née vous aider à piéger et
apparemment ça ne leur a pas plu voilà
donc alors adel
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de gens qui
attendent de savoir ce qui s'est
vraiment passé
déjà avant que tu nous dis sachez que on
avait déjà fait cette caméra cachée par
exemple avec nsa nous regardons regarder
ses dires il serait bien passé si je
suis je sais qu'ils jouent dans nos
chers voisins bardot
je pouvais arrêter je jouis de
laterrière
oh mon dieu
la tête qu'est ce que vous faites qu'est
ce que vous faites
bon c'est du droit on va voir regarder
quand même mais bon je vous n'êtes pas
en dieu vous arrêter pour faire pipi je
pense qu'on fait si ça avec tous vos
clients vous immiscer dans la ouate tu
te trompes et chemins je vais pas faire
pipi dans la voix du nord
je sais bien enfin écoutez vous vous
avez une double personnalité c'était
bien j'avais des côtés très attachant et
puis très bon d'ailleurs ça se passe
très bien voilà avec les deux et je fais
une petite interview avec anne nivat
voilà on va reprendre du temps depuis
début c'est vrai qu'à demi vague jean
jacques bourdin sont invités dans touche
pas à mon poste 27 janvier 2020 et anne
est très contente d'être la moitié je
suis très content de les voir anne nivat
et jean jacques bourdin bien ce que je
dis gelés qui fait vraiment j'étais
content qu'il soit dans l'émission
regardez
laquelle des deux a convaincu l'autre de
venir dans touche pas à mon poste c'est
qui ces gens-là dylan ces années merci
anna que j'ai eu très souvent au
téléphone ben ali merci mais c'était
alors matt reidy voilà donc ça s'était
très bien passé l'émission avait très
bien marché d'ailleurs avec anne et jean
jacques et donc après c'est vrai que
cette affaire est sortie il ya damien
mercereau
il ya d'abord michael holt aubenas qui
avait sorti le truc dans le parisien et
c'est vrai qu'après ils ont été
énormément interrogé sur cette histoire
que ce soit jean jacques bourdin ou anne
nivat et il ya plein de gens venus du
métier qui m'ont dit s'il te plaît cyril
fait une projo chez toi même plus qu'on
voit les images forcément bien sûr chez
plus les images vous dis la vérité parce
que ils m'ont demandé les voilà des
données de les jeter
on les a jetés parce qu'on est honnête
on l'a franchement c'est vrai donc on
les ajoute on les a pas gardé les images
donc moi je les ai jamais vu ces images
je vous ai jamais demandé ce qui s'était
réellement passé dans le taxi juste
après donc là ils sortent de l'émission
adèle vous êtes le faux chauffeur comme
vous avez fait là qu'est ce qui se passe
il arrive dans le dans le dans la
voiture il arrive dans la voiture c'est
vrai que le but c'était de les piéger
d'avoir leurs réactions
mais le but premier c'était d'avoir les
réactions de monsieur bourdin à nivet
était là forcément dons qu'ils arrivent
dans la voiture et
l'idée c'était de me faire passer pour
un fan donc j'étais fan de monsieur
bourdin donc c'est très simple je
commence le début j'avais un espèce de
scénario avec des intentions et l'idée
c'était voilà vous êtes monsieur bourdin
et là tout de suite elle me dit et pas
que je lui dis oui je sais vous êtes sa
femme non journaliste reporter de guerre
et si mon mari on est là aujourd'hui
c'est en grande partie grâce à moi ok
elle pose le décor très bien mais
c'était violent c'était pas ça c'est
d'arqués à limoux
non c'était d'arkham et la manière dont
s'était dit ça l'était moins d'accord
ouais donc je me suis pour la caméra
cachée avant même qu'elles commenceront
le ton est donné et je calme un peu et
cette histoire et tout ça ni bayrou avec
bandas dans la voiture lui aura fait
dépenser donc donc la première c'est le
début sa première punchline ok d'accord
je continue on roule
et puis petit à petit du scud pas
derrière dans la voiture à bon bah en
fait il sort de l'émission et forcément
il débrief sur leurs émissions alors un
mois contrairement à ce qu'on a pu voir
dans les articles à aucun moment je leur
ai dit qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cyril hanouna
jamais jamais c'est eux mêmes qui ont
débriefé de leurs émissions j'ai plus
les détails exacts et les mots pour mots
tout ce qui a été dit mais c'était voilà
des choses pas très sympathique au logis
sont dans l'oeil sont dans le truc
qu'est ce qu'ils disent dans la voiture
on veut savoir où on s'en fou maintenant
c'est un nazi de ce que je me rappelle
c'était que vous était un très mauvais
interviewer dans un bon cru le coeur et
c'est vraiment une très mauvaise une
carrière
bourreau avec vos chroniqueurs non mais
que c'était une émission de battre la
faux papas haut de gamme quoi c'est ce
que je me rappelle de ce fait virer de
la matinale
à chaque fois que je regardais les
rétroviseurs elle me disait enfin
j'entendais je suis pas en confiance je
parlerai pas ici et à s'arrêter de
parler donc après il ya plus grand chose
autour de démission surtout je me dis à
vous revenez pectinidés ça n'est plus
jean jacques où elle alors faut être
honnête jean jacques bourdin du début à
la fin il s'est très bien comportée il a
pas a rétorqué pas un mot plus haut que
l'autre ils étaient très calmes et sympa
mais franchement oui pour le coup oui
sa femme elle nous a défoncés c'était en
fait c'est juste qu'elle était ultra je
vais être honnête c'est la première fois
que dans une caméra cachée parce que
j'en ai fait plusieurs pour h2o que je
me suis senti en danger mais par rapport
à un niveau parce que la moindre chose
que je pouvais dire par rapport à son
mari s'était avoué m vous avez vous avez
la voix de dark vador est ce que peuvent
enregistrer un message en laissez nous
tranquilles mais taisez vous je vais
faire un mois l'application mais fermez
là c'était des insultes c'était de la
ville a dit quoi dit on s'en fout là
c'est simple c'était c'était taisez vous
mais c'est impossible mais vous êtes
complètement fou je voudrais vous avez
pas me juger non mais c'est pas ça vous
êtes complètement perturbé après ça
allait un peu dans le sens de la caméra
bon c'est vrai que vous êtes un peu
perturbé on hamm est oui mais j'ai pas
pu vraiment continuer mes propos à
chaque fois que je m'adresse à
jean-jacques elle intervenait et on en
est venu à un moment donné où j'ai senti
que c'était un peu chaud parce qu'elle a
dit bon tu veux pas lui [ __ ] une
claque mais d'une manière très sérieuse
donc je me suis retrouvé dans le sandjak
bourda il se retrouve dans la nasse et
jean jacques bourdin à chaque fois
c'était calme et vous monsieur laissez
nous tranquille s'il vous plaît mais il
était pas dérangé par mes questions ils
voyaient simplement qu'il y avait le
comportement de sa femme à côté
il essayait un petit peu de canaliser la
chose regarde moi je laisse à chaque
fois cinq ou huit minutes passées à un
moment donné il fallait que je tire de
la matière et que j'ai quelque chose
sauf que je n'avais pas de réaction de
jean jacques jamais uniquement les
réactions de sa femme
et c'est vrai qu'elle était pour le
moins violentes alors donc là c'était
effet combien de temps en voiture
s'était moins une trentaine de minutes
une trentaine de minutes en éclats
pendant tout le trajet vous vous essayez
de faire quoi pourquoi ne vous arrive
pas c'était à chaque fois je m'adresse à
monsieur bourdin c'était ce que je pour
enregistrer votre voix juste après vous
savez j'ai un scoop mais dimon s'en
foutent votre scoop
j non mais vraiment j'ai un scoop pour
vous il ya sarraf réseau qui va
rejoindre le casting des anges
[Rires]
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] taisez vous taisez
vous bon allez on sort de la voiture
elle a ouvert la voiture nantie pleine
rue ah ouais et il a dit ian metois
calme-toi finalement l'art certains vous
avez vous taire je vais écrire à
l'application
je vous met de très mauvais commentaires
enfin bref et puis arrive le moment moi
il faut savoir que quand on fait ce type
de caméra cachée se fait pas tout seul
c'est à dire qu'à une retransmission
dans une voiture suiveuse et il y avait
trois ou quatre personnes de l'équipe
qui pouvaient suivre en direct ce qui se
passait
et effectivement ils ont vu que ça
déconne et sauf qu'il ya eu un problème
c'est que j'ai perdu une oreillette
pendant le trajet d'accord et donc je
n'ai pas de lien avec eux j'étais un
petit peu voir moi-même et je devais un
petit peu jauger en fonction de leur
humeur
arrivés sur place vers le moment de leur
annonce que c'est une caméra cachée
moitié ou qui leur annonce c'est moi non
moi je me suis dit ça va la détendre
oui elle va ça va être bien vase ira
tranquille aussi au fond de cette
famille un coeur quand même et donc je
lui dit écoutez je trouve ma tête comme
ça des trois quarts monsieur bourdin
madame on y va je suis désolée c'était
une caméra cachée
pour cyril hanouna et la c ie pardon et
là tout de suite elle a ouvert la
voiture les équipes techniques qui
sortent derrière donc elle comprend ce
qui vient de lui arriver et je pense
qu'elle était en même temps choqué par
ses propos choquée par ce qu'elle a
donné en termes d'image et là elle s'est
jetée sur le capot de la voiture elle a
ouvert la portière
vous ne partez pas dit si elles sont les
images allaient essayer d'arracher des
caméras et de trouver les caméras
qu'elle n'a pas trouvé
elle a essayé tant bien que mal la
réalisation essayé de la rassurer
c'était il est où le comédien vous vous
êtes comédiens et un regarder dans les
mêmes termes à 10 dans toute la rue vous
est nullissime du vincou les gamins que
ces deux-là calmez vous la fait une
petite erreur on s'est dit qu'est ce
qu'il ya vous vous savez même pas parler
français français non mais vraiment
comme ça il y avait un ami restaurateur
elles qui étaient dehors à 10 heures
c'est un témoin c'est un témoin vous ne
partirez pas dit si elle est ouvert la
portière de trois-quarts aile s'est mis
dedans
elle a dit je veux les images et le son
et je ne sortirai pas je ne partirai pas
d'ici tant que je n'aurai pas à côté de
ça on à jean jacques bourdin on se dit
qu'est ce qu'il fait et qu'est ce qui
moi je me suis dit soutenir sa femme
ben non il la laisse en pleine rue je
pense qu'il ya deux streams on avait la
main
il qui s'est dit que c'est quoi cet
argent ça se fait pas et les parties et
elle est restée aux moins avouables
comment pendant 40-45 minutes je crois
qu'elle a essayé de joindre des équipes
de production sur la direction cacoub et
qui est directeur artistique chez h2o et
la décision a été prise parce que
c'était tout simplement ingérable de
supprimer l'intégralité des roches sauf
que elle voulait carrément qu'on
supprime tous les pièges qu'on avait
tourné avant non bassil et qu'on
supprime l'intégralité des rushes on lui
dit on va supprimer votre parti
qu'est-ce qui me prouve que vous avez
supprimé au chômage ou et leçons j'avais
envie de lui on va pas vous ramener un
objet vous n'allez pas la voir l'image
et le son on avait une espèce de
moniteurs vautours le réalisateur a
procédé normalement la suppression
devant elle de tout afin de
l'intégralité des roches
c'est incroyable histoire et jean
jacques bourdin un amour franchement
pour le coup bas je devais suscité une
réaction l'estuaire qui me fait le plus
de peine dans l'histoire crois que c'est
vraiment la réaction tout le monde la
joie sur les réseaux sociaux tout le
monde dit pauvre jean jacques cours
bourdin c'est vrai que c'est fou et
après s'est déguisé pas testé tut tut
tut tut tut réagit pas lui parler
non elle lui disait ben allez viens on
s'en va elle était toujours un ton au
dessus franchement très vulgaire
verbalement et ses violentes vraiment
elle faisait que de gigoter dans la
voiture tu veux pas lui [ __ ] une
claque et jean jacques bourdin tout
calme à côté bon bah voilà c'est vrai
pour nike se réveiller tôt si à l'époque
le point là il était fracassée à 21 mais
pour le coup à aucun moment je suis
confiant ce type de caméra cachée comme
vous le disait qu'on a fait avec nelson
monfort isabelle vitari clara morgane ça
s'est très bien passé c'est bon enfant
c'est du potage qui a rien
d'exceptionnel vador sarah fresu des
anges donc s'intéresser plutôt drôle en
plein et voilà ça m'est jamais arrivé et
c'est vrai que elle m'a pas mis elle m'a
pas mis bien et je m'en rappelle très
bien de cette caméra cachée comme d'hab
ils peur au moment où pas franchement je
me suis dit je vais me calmer parce qu'à
me foute une claque mais vraiment
vraiment pas elle était violente elle
était violente je connaissais pas cette
personne là je m'intéresse pas
particulièrement à vos fils s'est pas tu
vois là je la connais de nom pour moi
c'est avant voilà et c'était le piège il
était focalisée sur monsieur bourdin et
malheureusement elle a un petit peu
accaparé la chose et c'est vrai que
c'est dommage ça aurait été un très bon
rendu je pense qu'à l'antenne ça aurait
été parqués énorme c'est énorme je suis
dégoûté de pas pouvoir avoir revu les
images et les tout simplement de voir
les images de mon image mais on est on
est à fond dedans
oui le film mais c'est clairement le
profil de la femme castratrice et
profondément mon glaise et méchante ça
on n'en parle pas souvent et parfois il
est désormais sous pression la gorge
d'un homme qu'on appelle les canards et
on n'en parle pas c'est incroyable la
force de la rumeur parce que moi 7 je
n'avais évidemment jamais entendu parler
de ces images etc
il ya au moins 15 journalistes à
commencer par michael j'ai dû batailler
06 de cyrine tu l'appelles guillemot qui
m'ont appelé qu'est ce que tu sais pas
faire pipi quelques grenades du parisien
où damien mercereau des figaro tout maps
et tous les journalistes lundi cyril on
veut voir les images s'il te plaît mais
bon même en comité restreint même chez
toi voilà phénomène nos projections ya
même je vous le dis des tirs et je le
dis aux téléspectateurs il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de directeurs de grands patrons
de chaînes deux présidents de chaînes
qui m'ont appelé qui m'ont dit syrie
s'il te plaît mais si tu ne l'as pas
fait de soirée que c'est vrai ce n'est
pas une balade je vous le dis
franchement on m'a dit je te plaît cyril
gal et quand je vous dis les présidents
kane et réside en chaîne dus ils veulent
tous voir les images
moi ça m'étonne pascale nivelle a
toujours dit qu'elle supportait pas
qu'on dise que c'est la femme de risque
pour sa réaction la caméra cachée ça
m'étonne pas ensuite je trouve sa
réaction là elle est très décevante
parce que vous la prod h2 vous avez joué
le jeu vous avez pas diffuser les roches
vous les avez supprimé à sa demande
c'est extrêmement rare qu'on supprime
des roches dans un journal donc c'est
extrêmement rare de le demander et
franchement la grande race assez
d'émissions de divertissement c'est une
émission fiant à peu près qu'elle
veuille pas voilà benoît m moi ce que
j'aime pas les surtout les gens qui font
kiki qui sont très contents d'être ici
manifestement est derrière vous avez
joué le jeu vous avez accepté sa demande
qui est franchement amusé et elle vous
défonce derrière c'est un double langage
j'étais au rez de 2 me choque
profondément enfin cesser la base c'est
que ici effectivement le moi je me
souviens j'étais là fort sympathique et
c'est après boom et cisailles et sans
humour sans recul comme vous raconter
donc là je suis choquée de ne
m'attendais pas à tant de je dirais tant
de bassesse d'un couple comme ça que
j'admirais je suis vraiment déçu comme
en principe il est alors ça c'est fini
qu'on est resté au moins 40 45 minutes
et après avoir supprimé des images elle
a passé quarante mille coups de fil à
votre production à votre directeur
généra
pour savoir voilà pour être sûr que les
images soient bien supprimées que le
sont aussi soit bien supplie de me
demander si on va pas quand même essayé
de rouler flutto là c'est pas ça si je
me dis aussi avec un peu de recul
si par exemple ça avait été un vrai
chauffeur qui était vraiment fan de jean
jacques bourdin dont elle s'est
comportée
ouais je me dis waouh la pauvre personne
à ma place moi j'étais là je savais que
je joue un rôle c'est aussi mais la
personne qui aurait été là un monsieur
bourdin machin et bim bim des coûts
taisez vous fermez là laissez nous
tranquilles incroyable on a cumulé comme
ça je me dis c'est ça c'est fort quand
même comme comportement et c'est
démesuré mais vous l'avez eue depuis
vous aussi les plus jamais au téléphone
+ jamie benn deux matches ça on va
réussir à changer de bourdin quand même
voilà le haut jean jacques et je lui
fais voilà c'est pas grave et si on
retrouve les images ou les préviendra al
avance bien en toile à la ola vous savez
les procès on en a on en aura d'autres